wegen der ganzen schulz panik wegen der
tollen umfragewerte der spd musste der
herr seehofer sich jetzt sogar
öffentlich mit der kanzlerin versöhnt
höchststrafe wirklich er nicht
freiwillig zur erinnerung monatelang hat
seehofer herumgepöbelt werkelt ist
verstopft es unrechten springt heute und
jetzt sagt bettina die schon ok hat er
sich unwohl gefühlt bei dieser
pressekonferenz am montag
und das schöne ist seehofers anspannung
die kann ja tatsächlich geradezu
wissenschaftlich messen und zwar mit dem
motto meter funktioniert läuft
[Musik]
die auf
mehr anfangen ich war auch das holen was
mich sogar noch froh macht ist dass der
heute jetzt seinen aufgepeitschten csu
leuten erklären muss das sieht auch
wahlkampf für merkel machen müssen
ich wette das kommt riesig an an der
basis was machen die für merkel nicht
mal mehr das mindeste tun
plakate kleben holland würde hatte ich
kann mir da ist keine liebe mehr oder